GOVERNOR OPENING UP HER SALONS
ON FRIDAY, RESTAURANTS ON
MONDAY.
HARRIS?
>> Harris: GRIFF JENKINS,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT.
I WANT TO BRING IN FORMER
ARKANSAS GOVERNOR AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR MIKE DUBKE A DULL
MIKE HUCKABEE.
GREAT TO SEE YOU, GOVERNOR
I WATCH THAT LIFE WITH THE
PRESIDENT EARLIER, AND HE DID
SAY THAT IF HE SEE SOMETHING
GOING SOUTH IN TERMS OF HOW
PEOPLE ARE SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
CERTAIN AREAS, THAT HE’S GOING
TO SNAP BACK WITH A RESPONSE.
WE’VE SEEN HIM DO THAT BEFORE.
>> AND I THINK THAT’S EXACTLY
WHAT WE OUGHT TO BE DOING.
WE TOOK A DRACONIAN ACTION AS A
NATION.
FRANKLY, EVERYBODY DID.
THE WHOLE WORLD.
BECAUSE WE REALLY WEREN’T SURE
JUST HOW FAST THIS VIRUS WOULD
BEGIN TO MOVE.
NOW WE HAVE A MUCH BETTER
PICTURE OF IT.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT MITIGATION
WORKS.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT’S RIGHT,
OPEN THE ECONOMY BACK UP.
LET GOVERNORS MAKE THE
DECISIONS.
LOCAL, MAYORS, COUNTY OFFICIALS.
IF THERE DOES SPRING UP ANOTHER
PROBLEM, ADDRESS THE PROBLEM.
BUT DON’T SHUT EVERYBODY.
30 MILLION PEOPLE OUT OF WORK,
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHAT THAT’S
DOING TO US.
IT’S DESTROYING NOT JUST THE
ECONOMY, BUT THE SPIRIT AND THE
WILL AND THE RESILIENCE OF
AMERICANS.
THAT IS OUR GREATEST ASSET.
>> Harris: YOU KNOW WHO AGREES
WITH YOU, IS FORMER GOVERNOR OF
NEW JERSEY CHRIS CHRISTIE.
HE HAD THESE VERY RAW WORDS TO
SAY ABOUT REOPENING.
WATCH.
>> I THINK THAT’S WHAT WE NEED
FROM GOVERNORS NOW, SOME
BOLDNESS AND SOME INGENUITY.
AND HONESTY TO THE PEOPLE.
IN THE END, YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE
TO TELL THEM, "PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO DIE, AND IT’S GOING TO BE
AWFULLY SAD."
WHAT ARE THOSE LABS GOING TO
WORKBEWORTH IF PEOPLE CAN’T SPRI
FAMILIES, IF THEY BECOME
HOMELESS?
IF THEY HAVE TO GO TO FOOD BANKS
EVERY WEEK TO BE ABLE TO FEED
THEIR FAMILIES?
THAT’S NOT SUSTAINABLE, EITHER.
>> Harris: GOVERNOR HUCKABEE,
OUR GOVERNOR IS GOING BE WILLING
TO DO THAT?
TO SACRIFICE LABS ALONG THE WAY?
>> I DON’T THINK IT’S A MATTER
OF SACRIFICING LIVES.
A LOT OF US HAVE DONE WHAT WE’VE
DONE, NOT BECAUSE WE WERE SCARED
FOR OURSELVES, BUT WE DIDN’T
WANT TO SUBJECT OTHER PEOPLE TO
THE ANXIETIES OR POTENTIAL IF WE
WERE CARRYING THE VIRUS.
I THINK NOW OR AT A POINT WERE
ABLE TO SAY TO PEOPLE, "IF
YOU’RE NERVOUS AND FEARFUL THAT
YOU’RE ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
VULNERABLE, STAY HOME.
STAY OUT OF THE WORKFORCE."
BUT THE REST OF US ARE GOING TO
GO BACK TO LIVING.
WE CAN’T STAY HUNKERED DOWN IN
BUNKERS FOR THE REST OF OUR
LIVES.
IF WE GO OUT, WE GO OUT KNOWING
THAT THERE IS PERHAPS A RISK.
I’LL TELL YOU, THERE IS NO RISK
AND CONTINUING TO SHUT THE
ECONOMY DOWN.
WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THAT
TAKES PLACE.
WE ALL START TO SUFFER.
WE SEE THAT, AND I THINK A LOT
OF AMERICANS ARE SAYING, "A FEW
OF US MAY GET SICK, BUT WE’RE
ALL HURTING RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE
NONE OF US HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GO
OUT FOR THE LAST EIGHT WEEKS."
>> Harris: YEAH.
I WANT TO MOVE ONTO THIS, THE
PRESIDENT TAKING SOME HEAT AND
SOME QUESTIONS, IF YOU WILL COME
ABOUT WHY HE WILL NOT LET
DR. FAUCI TESTIFY BEFORE THE
HOUSE.
SENATE.
>> THE HOUSE IS A SENATE, THE
HOUSE IS A BUNCH OF TERM PAGERS.
THEY PUT EVERY HATER ON THE
COMMITTEE, THE SAME OLD STUFF.
THEY FRANKLY WANT OUR SITUATION
TO BE UNSUCCESSFUL, WHICH MEANS
DEATH.
IT MEANS DEATH.
OUR SITUATION IS GOING TO BE
VERY SUCCESSFUL.
>> Harris: WOW.
THOSE ARE SOME PRETTY STRONG
WORDS AGAINST THE OPPOSING
PARTY, GOVERNOR.
>> WELL, IT’S SOME PRETTY STRONG
NONSENSE THAT THE OPPOSING PARTY
HAS THROWN AT THE PRESIDENT,
FROM THE PHONY IMPEACHMENT
NONSENSE TO THE FACT THAT EVERY
DAY THEY BLAME HIM FOR SOMETHING
ELSE REGARDING THE CORONAVIRUS.
WHEN, IN FACT, HE HAS RESPONDED
SO WELL THAT HE HAS DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNORS WHO DON’T EVEN LIKE
HIM SAYING NICE THINGS ABOUT HIM
AND APPRECIATING THE FACT THAT
HE HAS BEEN RESPONSIVE TO THEM.
THE REASON THAT DR. FAUCI
SHOULDN’T GO AND TESTIFY TO
CONGRESS IS BECAUSE THE
CONVERSATIONS AND DISCUSSIONS
THAT HE HAS HAD WITH THE
PRESIDENT ARE IN THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH, WHERE THEY SHOULD
REMAIN.
IF YOU TAKE CONVERSATIONS,
CANDID CONVERSATIONS THAT A
PRESIDENT CAN HAVE WITH THE
PEOPLE SURROUNDING HIM, AND YOU
START HAVING
POLITICALLY-CHARGED, HATEFUL
PEOPLE, LIKE EXIST IN THE
DEMOCRAT HOUSE, JUST TRYING TO
EXPOSE AND CAUSE TROUBLE IN THE
MIDST OF A PANDEMIC, PRESIDENTS
WILL NEVER SURROUND THEMSELVES
WITH PEOPLE LIKE DR. FAUCI
AGAIN.
THAT IS THE DANGER WE WOULD
FACE.
NOT THAT WE WON’T KNOW WHAT
DR. FAUCI THINKS.
I THINK IT’S PRETTY CLEAR,
HARRIS, THIS IS NOT A GUY WHO IS
A SHRINKING VIOLET.
HE GOES AND SAYS WHAT HE THINKS,
RIGHT IN THE PRESENCE OF THE
PRESIDENT.
BUT THE PRESIDENT IS NOT GOING
TO TROT THESE PEOPLE UP TO
CONGRESS SO THEY CAN GET
SKEWERED BY THE LIKES OF
ADAM SCHIFF.
>> Harris: INTERESTING.
ARI FLEISCHER ON WITH ME LAST
HOUR ON "OUTNUMBERED" SAID
PERHAPS HE LET THE SENATE GO
FIRST, AND THE HOUSE COME SECOND
SO EVERYBODY GETS A BITE.
I SAID, "YOU KNOW, THERE ARE
DEMOCRATS IN THE SENATE.
THEY CAN ASK QUESTIONS, TOO.
WHY DO YOU HAVE TO BE IN THE
MAJORITY TO ASK THE QUESTIONS?
CAN’T YOU JUST PARTICIPATE?"
BUT THAT’S MY OPINION.
WE WILL SEE DOCTOR DR. FAUCI AND
DIRECTOR REDFIELD IN FRONT OF